Elegance is an interesting concept.
It's very controversial.
In fact,
if you,
one of the things that continually
happens over and over again in
psychology is that psychologists
discover all sorts of new kinds of
intelligence and you know,
the biggest two proponents of that sort
of thing.
I suppose we're Bob Sternberg who came
up with this thing equaled practical
intelligence.
And then Howard Gardner who came up with
the theory of multiple intelligences
which had a very large effect on
educational psychology,
um,
when the theory was first proposed.
And that's not saying much because
generally speaking,
it's very difficult to find a discipline
that's more susceptible to fads than
educational psychology.
And as far as I can tell,
generally speaking,
each fat is worse than the previous one.
So,
you know,
Gardner positive that I think there were
seven.
Oh,
there they are,
seven or eight different intelligence,
linguistic,
musical,
logical,
mathematical,
spacial body,
kinesthetic,
intrapersonal and interpersonal.
And people talk about emotional
intelligence and they talk about
practical intelligence.
And as far as I'm concerned,
all of that is complete rubbish.
And there's technical reasons for that.
I mean there's technical and
philosophical reasons for that.
The first thing is you can't just mess
up a word,
you know,
the whole point of having a word is so
that it defined some things that
described some things and doesn't
describe other things.
Right,
and so you can.
You can make the word intelligence a
current for whatever you want,
so you can say that the ability to dance
as a form of intelligence,
but the problem with that is you blur
out the word so badly.
You can't tell what it means anymore.
And so,
and I would also point out we had
perfectly good words for those major
intelligence as we called them talents
and so it's perfectly reasonable to make
a distinction between the talent and
intelligence.
Now you might say,
well,
how the hell do you know the difference?
Like if if things look similar to some
degree,
then how do you know if they're the same
or different?
Well,
that's exactly what you do when you do
the construct validity process.
So let's say you rated a number of
people on their dancing ability and then
you rated the number of people on their
ability to multiply two digit,
two,
two digit numbers in their head quickly
while then you see,
technically if both of those were
intelligences,
then the people who could dance better
could multiply two digit numbers faster
in their head and that they would be
slightly positive story.
See,
that's what happens when I don't have
any diet coke.
So anyways,
if intelligence was the right word to
subsume both of those,
then what you see is that would be a
high correlation that people who are
good dancers would also be the ones who
could multiply most rapidly.
And I mean multiply in their head,
um,
but that,
but you're not going to be able to
extract out a single factor like that.
It's just not,
it's just not the case that those things
associate like that.
So for something to be one phenomena,
the things that it.
Obviously I've talked too much this
semester,
all the things that are subsumed under
that definition have to be correlated
and highly correlated because otherwise
they're not the same thing.
It's the definition of the same thing.
Now,
Iq is a very peculiar construct,
a very unique construct from a
psychological perspective,
but also more generally from a social
science perspective because Iq has the
most predictive validity of anything
ever discovered in the social sciences
period.